hey everybody welcome to found oh my
plan here with a dark prestige Leo necro
and Christian my name is now hello this
is from a hundred subscriber special can
we not kill is not from iwan just sharp
special whoa that's weird strike there's
a hundred subscribers why are you
hitting your teammate well it's not you
know haha tunnel lag I know I'm getting
like cool 60 cool 60 frames cuz fret I
have a set of 60 frames what I went from
um can we not from 60 all the way down
to like six and they like that and then
back down and back up and back up oh
well we are playing 3v3 battle dome if
you guys know Donald battle dome is
basically you get materials and you kill
people or you break the block boom
summary of battle them boom you got try
to take the team's obsidian that's the
breaking the block yeah oh we're doing
another intro guys I'm just gonna
continue my interest you get to intros
have birthday okay we're restarting I'll
do this we count down checker three two
one hey everybody welcome with some
battle dollar plan here with dark and
necro Leo Christian and metal easy yeah
we're doing battle dome here on the
server and it's gonna be a lot of fun
we're playing 3v3 me dark and let met
leu you burst yeah no row and Christian
he's trying to steal the city man that's
so uh you don't have to play let's do
that for you will take you throughout
the game but we're gonna go ahead and
get started so see you guys at the end
yeah I gotta go run down a pepper pepper
pepper wait I was keeping score 15
minutes ya ali who's got out we uh we
got this guy's
I'm not even concerned at all you just
got sitting from the chest boy look at
it later I get it right now Oh strikers
who you striker not gonna die with it
he's like old struck is gonna go to
later I'm gonna get now I'm getting it
now all right so I think we should
definitely okay let's see how it goes if
we get enough materials and stuff and
then headed toward them we should see
what they're doing if they already have
a base in the sky then we should get one
this guy there on the ground scappini
champagne who stay out of sky base then
we should definitely get up but if not
that we can try to rush them and get
there we're gonna need signal quickly
yeah I'll get food but you can do /
healing stuff and / the 15 minutes right
yeah for shifting o P is hack hook get
enough wood for the whole trip so those
of you who don't are not familiar with
battled on basically there's two teams
and uh we we start off fighting to the
death and we have 15 minutes to prep and
I feel something is gonna tell us
whenever 15 meet ya cuz you Jack at the
time so that's the edge okay I'm not
been able to find a cave up for cave
what have I / / is it feed such feed ya
must read I'll get two pics this is not
a tax let's get a shovel me have you
guys played battle dome at all uh never
played one game battle dome but you have
offensive video yes no okay that's these
videos and I played a few times I'm
getting all the call this my first like
recorded battle dome not on like some
public server them so nice is my first
one as well striker look at all these
achievements were getting yeah minecraft
achievements man so I can't believe that
Kirsten one season three UHC
that dot all right anyway um damn it you
have to go along with it what the [ __ ]
what is time to mind me know I know you
flanks and sticks to make a pic good job
i'm just showing the people because
sometimes they could be slow do they
care about the achievement though yeah
don't be it's it's very bright i have 25
coal yeah i have seven get up i get away
from this uh the dome i'm lagging every
time I look over the dome I didn't even
know we made it don't instantly so
there's only diamond don like the far
edges of it or is that vedula done okay
i don't even know if that happened we
tried it in the crash the server both
times we tried to it should i pick up
all the woods i'm dropping frames like
crazy right now what's going on here
stop looking at the dome I'm looking
down dude yeah but the egg I've helped
strange what the hell ya want me to
stick together no definitely we're
sticking together for pansies I'm at the
dome that's that goes all around the map
cave you gotta be kidding me man oh no
oh is that case yes s cave oh yeah when
they want to be clear with you guys I
have the Obsidian on my hotbar why don't
I hear the mob was open this lag I don't
get like at all like any time and I'm
having to go to like super low settings
and such clara was likewise why don't I
him up and i'm still like dropping I'm
good
so no Oh Christian finally made his
first crafting banjo haha i'm back in
all this cave I need feet alright so
just it is / fee than your name and that
feeds you yeah okay you know this must
be actually ok / beautiful save you time
oh oh I backed into a corner with mobs
it's not good marriage it's a lot of a
lot of food before we I have no food but
I have good amount of coal and you have
a good amount of / feed that's true I'm
gonna kill this witch I have infinite /
feed if I've got a healing potion from
the witch nice I thought you run a cave
I'm happy now holy crap why what is it
with this leg the game I'm right back
aren't you yeah yeah freeway yeah gang
like constant intan i'm getting the
constant like lag spikes not for in for
frame bomb being like didn't lag i got i
just recently get in this coal I got a
few things of um blocks replacing a fair
break them but it's the only lack of
experience so for TTP into teammates
should we just do TP and the teammate
name yep oh good this is a cave I don't
know let's find out I'm gonna break the
glass I near I don't think it'll work
I'm near a stack of coal I don't glass
by accident no [ __ ] i did on purpose cuz
nobody's the biggest threat on pvp so we
like if we run into him bush we focus on
I have no idea Nikoli oh yeah I don't
know I could well I'm dude I'm the weak
link as my shitty computer just want to
know that so I'm pop I have to probably
stay back and shoot with a bow but other
than that I'll be fine that's another
thing we need to focus on some arrows
and get some cold that that was not um
a cave and all was not it was not a cave
as small passageway wait so we need
Flint right yeah I'm getting some gravel
okay as am i oh hey look Middlebury I
can see I'm gonna make us a friend just
respond to my face I was like what okay
i could pay yo you do this do what I
won't do this you sitting from making
furnaces and stuff I had to do something
cuz i got calming of coal I got iron man
I had no iron the mobs probably gonna
start pooping on me I've got I've got
600 I have zero remember to keep on that
was helpful I keep remembering to keep
on mining even if you get enough for
yourself cuz we yeah I have none so what
do you think their plan of attack will
be I don't know you think they'll be on
the offensive the defense I think let's
go your zombie I'd be more defensive I
zama can we get a hit who first one to
get monster hunter I think no I'm i know
i got all the oh I'll tell you this i
think if we played this the right way we
should play the defense and let them
come to us we should build like a sky
base with lava pouring out everywhere
that's nothing gonna get some lava
ambitious didn't even think about it I
ran 32 iron now uh-oh there are so many
there's so many mobs I'm gonna TP I have
12 Flint's at seven UTPB to me prestige
I could what's okay I to complete what's
your thing tag thingy Starla Zeus like
she's okay okay
yes hello hi but I've cleaned up in this
review look at all this Cole here dark
which was here dark all right behind you
Corey yeah yeah yeah Hagel okay I'm
gonna hmm let's see I'm gonna build up
and try to continue going on through
that cave we should make another furnace
where is that I thought its appear- hyah
sighs screw you'll find us I didn't make
it up before we get to the end here oh
you came up here to striker okay yep
look you hear the siren that's outside
nope oh yeah we definitely need a
definitely need a new furnace if you
have that much stuff cooking bro I've
already made one who is little cook is
he of everything in one furnace yes he
is all 30 that's really inefficient plus
45 are I'm putting 15 at the other one
see doesn't matter if we're efficient or
not yes we applaud your efficiency I'll
give a [ __ ] that's nice time doe time
okay I think we're good on coal for now
at least that's Oh Rick could be five
minutes in a couple second striker uh
okay oh we should collect this lava guys
we should collect this lava I'm guessing
so want me to make an iron bucket and
collect the lava can you make a gold but
I go ahead oh snap yeah quite hard work
all hardware that's a Vegas more here we
go all right how much irony we have in
total we need 26 for each of us um
whatever book it would agree all right
I'm putting six in the chest I put six
iron in the chest and I made a big
history all right bucket bucket aam
the name